[Music]
[Applause]
check in with our buddy Jamal Crawford
NBA on TNT analyst and was Sixth Man of
the Year three times played for nine
teams over 20 Seasons great to see you
again how's the jumper
still sweet play last night good to see
you as well Dan okay your son is a sixth
grader
sixth grade yes is he being recruited
right now
I wouldn't say he's being recruiter
right now but
people know about him right now and
that's interesting to me because I
wasn't known until I was 16. but as a
parent how do you keep your sixth grade
son like grounded from the that hey you
know you got a long time before you get
to college basketball here yes we had a
talk before we actually start playing
AAU before he started playing and I told
him I said you know what some people are
going to say you're good some people
gonna say you're not good and some
people are going to say you're okay
either way we got to be okay with the
way just continue to get better it's a
long journey so he's had a good attitude
about everything so far so it's worked
out how tall is he
he's five nine right now actually he's
he's trying to pass mom I think they're
saying
she's gonna start wearing her high heels
it doesn't happen uh I'm on the Laker
bandwagon here
are you
you're not
it's not that I'm not I believe they
were built for the playoffs but
I mean I like reads a lot I love A.D
obviously LeBron is LeBron he's one of
the great ones of all time but I'm just
not exactly sure yet as they Advance
because I think they can get this around
but as they advance I don't know
I think they made smart moves at the
deadline instead of going after Kyrie
you know you already had the failed
mistake with Russell Westbrook and I
think they're a better all-around team
and you might be right that they're
built for the playoffs
um and this match up with Memphis
because Memphis you know all they do is
talk and now with job being injured
um see I I think there everybody has
holes in the west like you sold on
Denver being the best team out west no
I'm not actually I actually had gone
into it I had Golden State and Phoenix
versus the field I thought those two
teams could actually you know be better
than anybody else in the west but I
could see the Lakers being right there
as well when the game slows down
LeBron's at his best right and he's a
chess master and I always said for the
Lakers to go where they want to go
LeBron has to be their fourth quarter
guy ID has to be and the other guys have
to be their first third quarter guys to
kind of carry him so he can collect data
and pick teams apart and then that's
when he'll take over and make his move
okay I I like the Suns but then of
course they lose to the Clippers Inc Why
without Paul George uh how does that
happen
I think it happens when you're in the
playoffs for the first time trying to
figure it out I mean obviously Kevin
Durant's the best player but him taking
just 15 shots uh for me is not enough
I'm sure he'll increase his
aggressiveness out goals as it goes on
where's Kauai gonna end up historically
that's the unbelievable question Dan
because
like right now right I don't know if
he's top five player in the regular
season but I know he's top five player
in the playoffs just because the way he
plays uh what's important to him what's
driving him he's been a champion for a
long time and when you have that that's
what really get your juices going and to
do what he did yesterday and it wasn't
like it's a hot night for him he can do
that every single night and that's why
he's special but why doesn't he play
more
I think injuries I think when you go
through injuries I think it changed you
a little bit you know you become a lot
more cautious you become more
um
just more cautious you absolutely are
but he knows it's his time to shine yeah
it's just I'm surprised when he plays
really yeah when he plays I know he's
going to play at a high level I'm just
never sure if he's going to play
yeah yeah he's he's he's went through a
couple injuries but I think hey if this
is the time we get to see him and when
it's at the stakes are the highest and
we see him most will sign up for it what
does she like do you know him oh
unbelievable guy very funny I knew you
were I knew you were going to say that
yes Jamal I need proof that yeah I know
right uh he
very talkative uh very fun very normal I
think okay Jamal people say this about
Bill Belichick they'll be like man is he
funny and I'll go no he's not oh wait
right life of the party so if you go to
kawhi's Twitter right I'm one of six
people he follows from way back in the
face for a long time it's crazy it's
like Wingstop uh Jordan to me it's like
it was crazy because I've known
and he's been the same he's always been
very about his business about getting
better
um and very funny he's always been very
funny it's incredible all right I'll
take your word for it trust me okay all
right talking to Jamal Crawford NBA on
TNT analyst who's the underdog in the
Sacramento Golden State series
I think sack is Underdog even though he
finished third I think sack's a underdog
Golden State
they were bumpy all year but to end up
in the sixth spot and you just trust
them in playoffs they had a chance the
other night but Sacramento still strong
golden state is going to be a tough out
because they know what it takes they can
lock down they can go on those stops
they can go on those runs that are
historic right and I think they still
have that switch and they're out to
prove it for sure
is it easier to explain Steph Curry's
greatness or Klay Thompson's greatness
for me I think it's it's easier to
explain uh Clays but Steph's anomaly
like this little six three guard changed
the way basketball is viewed the way
it's played I coach a right and to be in
any gym in America and see guys shoot
and turn around before it goes in or the
doe behind the backs every kid now
believes that you can make it to the NBA
because of this guy because the way he's
made it look the way he's he's been the
boy next door of the steps an assassin
man he's special he's an all-time great
and he might have created Caitlin Clark
at Iowa
see and there's gonna be more players
like that yeah you don't have to be you
know LeBron's size or Jordan size or
Kobe size you can be a 6-3 guard and say
you know what I can I can out hustle you
I I can have just as much hard as
anybody on the court and my skills can
be transcending where you know what my I
may have a shot to make it but is there
anybody who's had a better career in
dribbling less
than Klay Thompson
no not at all Clay is the bigger the
moment the bigger the shot the better
Clay is Clay's one of those guys he'll
make a tough one like ooh clay you make
that one oh we're ready to go because he
he's a Fearless shooter right and when
you have that that's a that's a weapon
think about the games he had against OKC
in the past their first Finals run they
could have lost that and not had this
dynasty based off what happened Clay is
unbelievable I'm glad he's healthy I'm
glad he's he's back showing he's at top
tier level and I'm glad it's worked out
for him because he's been through a lot
of the last few years I don't know if I
can take the Knicks advancing because
the fans the Nick fans you know party
like it's 1999. I I I mean you know the
Hawks they beat the Hawks one game and
you know you had these Bros with their
shirts off celebrating in New York last
year and now with the Cavaliers and and
you know what maybe it's a great story
but did you see that next Jersey back
there I played there we had no shot at
the playoffs we won mid 25 to 30 games
in the year they made it feel like a
playoff atmosphere every single night so
I can't imagine being in the city right
now winning the game and seeing the
people's reaction because like you said
if they Advance it's gonna be like it's
party like it's 1999. for sure uh but
who would you see celebrity wise besides
Spike Lee when you played you were in
New York for what five years yes almost
five years Adam Sandler uh Jay-Z P Diddy
Spike of course I remember one game uh
Samuel Jackson was there at the game and
we're sitting across from each other I
think he said it was fight and my hand
was wrapped so I wasn't playing he came
in the suit he's like you're not playing
I said nice oh only
that was really really cool and last
part of that I actually just got an
email uh probably like a couple months
ago and a guy emailed my foundation and
he said hey just want to let you know
that Heath Ledger was at the game when
you scored 52 and I knew that part and
he said we hung out with Jay-Z
afterwards and that was he's first
basketball game and you kind of helped
spark him get into basketball and
playing afterwards so you had a Heath
Ledger fan which is pretty cool what was
it like hanging out with Jay-Z
oh it was really cool he was always so
cool and it was funny because all those
celebs we talked about I was always a
little bit more nervous when he was
there so I wouldn't look at him until I
got like eight or ten points
I was like all right he's there now I I
see you but I saw him the whole time I
just wouldn't let him know uh so you got
uh the Phoenix Suns or Golden State
coming out of the West still
I do with the Lakers being that Dark
Horse okay now East you know the James
Harden storyline is really quiet Jamal
and
you know we I think because he's almost
settled back into I'm gonna pass first
shoot less less drama and we've only
talked about Joel embiid we haven't
really talked about the Sixers as a team
and it's all positive
I I don't know how dangerous you think
Philadelphia is but man if I was gonna
their odds are long but I would I would
jump on that because I think they're
everybody's talking about Boston or or
uh Milwaukee right no and with that
situation it's interesting because Joel
said something after the game that I've
been saying all year we love James being
the point guard but at some point if
they Advance they continue to advance
he's gonna have to be more aggressive to
score the ball as well like I love you
know 22 Point 13 assists James Harden
but at certain point we're gonna need 28
points Tennessee's James harness it goes
forward because Joel's gonna need that
second guy as they continue to advance
okay Doc's playing well but he has that
gear but he's going to show up more as
it continues to go further but he's
playing unbelievable right now be in
that point guard who do you like coming
out of the East
I still like Boston okay I like
Milwaukee and I think Milwaukee is
better against everybody else but I
think Boston can actually match up with
Milwaukee and do some damage in the
playoffs they had a game late in the
season where I thought Boston absolutely
was trying to send a message and they
did that I think it was the last time
they played it we always talk about
playoff basketball you know it's
different or the calls that you would
make like a playoff foul yes can you
describe the difference in the feel of a
regular season and the feel of a
postseason game
the regular season is just free-flow
right there's there's any kind of
contacts and foul everybody's scoring
it's more like an All-Star game setting
in the playoffs Dan let's say we we were
playing right and we're going to 15 and
it's 14-14 and that last point is
aggressive it's tough you're not getting
anything free that's how every single
possession is in the playoffs and that's
why you're exhausted afterwards that's
why you've left it all in the court
that's why you have scars and you know
things of that nature bumps and bruises
you didn't even feel until after the
game because every single possession is
is definitely intense and that's why I
rather see the score and be down in the
playoffs but the points mean more like
if you got 20 points in the playoff game
you earned it it was no freebies you
really earned those points no JJ Redick
has been on record talking about you
know that everybody talks about how
tough the game was back in the 90s and
as
you know it's it's uh he thinks it's as
physical or it's overrated how physical
it was back then and I said to him the
greatest player in the history of the
sport
got knocked down every time he went to
the hoop by the Detroit Pistons there
was no you know you can say there's Star
Treatment but you know they they wrote a
book called The Jordan rules about
beating up Michael Jordan they're not
writing any books about beating up Joe
Ellen bead
no and I agree with you Dan uh I love JJ
performance he made one of my my close
friends but absolutely was more physical
not just the physicality if when you get
continuously beat like that when you're
going to the basket it's gonna play on
you mentally too do you really want
those two points
every single time so the physical is one
thing but to play off the mentor is
something else so it was definitely more
physical back in the day well I could
hand check you
not only hand checked you can hand check
and guide somebody where you wanted them
to go like you can physically say no
Derek Harper was the best at it he would
guide you where he wanted you to go so
two points then to me it meant a lot
more because it was just so hard to get
okay but could Steph Curry be Steph
Curry back then given how you know how
you could play
Steph Curry anyway and that's what's
special about him because he's one of
the few stars that don't ruin the flow
of offense because he moves so much yeah
you can shoot like that off the move and
she like that off the handle you'd be
transcending any error and he's Steph
would be stepping at any time no
question he's the greatest shooter of
all time no question because most guys
can talk about the Regis the Rays they
do it mostly with somebody else creating
the offense form not saying they
couldn't do it off the dribble he does
it off of both and and the the space he
creates the gravity he pulls like he's
shooting five feet six feet seven feet
behind the three-point line with
confidence so when you do that you give
space to everybody else and that's
another way to make your teammates okay
one three
you're gonna pass to somebody
or you're gonna take it yourself so game
seven the one guy in NBA history you
want taking the three with the game on
the line is who let me take you out of
it because you should you should pick
yourself yeah right the one person
that you won't take in that three Steph
Curry and the reason why is let's say I
ran a play for him and he came off a pin
down if he didn't have it he can still
create something off the dribble to
create anything you can give him this
much space and and Steph Curry's great
the tough shots too his threes are worth
more than anybody else's in history
because they're so deflated some people
in the in the stands are doing this some
are cheering some are like I can't
believe I just saw Steph Curry's the one
guy I want to take that shot God I just
can't imagine what it's like to go out
there and know there is the potential
being embarrassed what do you guys get
embarrassed when you're guarding
somebody who's supposed to be great for
sure he absolutely is trying to
demoralize you as well he'll do it with
a smile and it's it's incredible because
he's the boy next door but his he's an
assassin so he he thrives off that he
becomes a bigger monster he goes from
six three to seven feet because he's
he's taking your fans making him his
he's he's getting Joy with everybody
else and he's trying to turn lights out
and then you watch it and the ball
doesn't touch the net like it just the
net doesn't even move it's like oh my
gosh well I know he and Steve Kerr would
have these free throw shooting contests
that if you you had to squish it like
you couldn't hit rim or if you did then
that counted as a miss and it's almost
like I'm surprised when Steph does draw
Iron with anything it's just that pure
yeah it's a different level of shooting
that's like Perfection shooting right
it's not about even making the shots I
wanted to go in where it doesn't it
doesn't touch anything right how many
strands did it touch up there oh no okay
well that's that's a good shot for me oh
great to talk to you and uh hopefully
we'll catch up again and uh good luck
you know more importantly being a parent
oh it's the coolest thing thanks so much
now do you want him to be like you or
like Steph
let's do somewhere in between if you can
have a boat I think he'll be all right
there's no nio yet for your sixth grader
no okay that's coming we're still it is
but as long as he keeps the Love of the
Game everything else will take care of
itself good to talk to you again thank
you Jamal thank you that's uh Jamal
Crawford